[Música]
carlos estuvo a la sombra de su madre
toda su vida
no tenía ni cinco años cuando se
convirtió en heredero al trono nacido el
14 de noviembre de 1948 el primer hijo
de la princesa elisabeth y el príncipe
felipe el niño que va a ser rey tuvo que
acostumbrarse a que todos sus
movimientos fueran seguidos de cerca el
pequeño de buen comportamiento y
sensible tuvo que lidiar rápidamente con
la ausencia de sus padres cuyas
obligaciones los mantenían a menudo
alejados hasta entonces todos sus
predecesores habían tenido un tutor
privado pero a los 8 años se convirtió
en el primer monarca en espera de
asistir a la escuela a la edad de 14
años carlos fue enviado a escocia al
notoriamente duro internado al que su
padre había asistido en córdoba
en el verano de 1969 con 20 años le
dieron el título que llevaría durante
los siguientes 53 años el de príncipe de
gales un título que ostenta el heredero
al trono británico desde el siglo 14
siguiendo la tradición familiar
carlos pasaría a sus siguientes siete
años sirviendo a las fuerzas armadas
mientras seguía preparándose para sus
futuras funciones
su época más difícil llegó a la década
de 1990 tras la ruptura de su matrimonio
con diana y su sorprendente muerte los
acontecimientos hicieron que el
entusiasmo por carlos cayera en picado y
algunos pidieron su abdicación pero con
el tiempo se ha reconciliado con el
público en los últimos años de la reina
cuando ella empezó a tener problemas con
su agotadora agenda carlos dé un paso al
frente para asumir más responsabilidades
aún no ha conseguido la misma
popularidad que su difunta madre y ahora
después de 70 años preparándose para el
papel todos esperan saber qué clase de
rey sera